and so the president says to the head of
the taliban he said look we all want to
end the violence
but if you break this deal we're going
to hit you harder than we've ever hit
you before and you could just hear in
the tone
of the taliban leader that he understood
that
and literally the fact that there was
not an american casualty for 18 months
proves my point
that they knew we meant business
[Music]
so this week we had the opportunity to
sit down with vice president mike pence
and talk about all things under the sun
we'll get to that in just one moment
first this interview is brought to you
by our friends over at zip recruiter the
lockdown's the last year and a half they
created this huge pent-up demand for
places like gyms nail salons hotels all
of them are on an epic hiring spree to
accommodate a surge of business so where
do these businesses turn to fill roles
fast zip recruiter right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter they send your job to over 100
top job sites giving you access to their
network of millions of job seekers zip
recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and then proactively
presents them to you you can easily
review recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
that encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates in fact zip recruiter
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post to unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com
dailywire at ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just go to
ziprecruit.com dailywirezippercareer is
indeed the smartest way to hire we're
joined on the line by vice president
mike pence who of course was vice
president of the united states during
the trump administration he has a brand
new podcast out titled american of
freedom in partnership with our friends
over young america's foundation vice
president thanks so much for joining the
show i really appreciate it you bet ben
it's great to be on the bench shapiro
show i'm a big fan
congrats on the uh congrats on the new
podcast and wish you a lot of luck with
it what's the subject of the podcast
going to be how often does it come out
where can people get it
well we're looking to do it on a regular
basis like you
i'm going to be hitting the road heading
to college campuses for young america's
foundation
starting this fall but we also thought
pairing that with a podcast that's
entitled american freedom with mike
pence talking about the issues of the
day bringing my background and
experience from being vice president
being a governor being in congress to
lend a conservative perspective
and hopefully with particular emphasis
to young people you're such an important
voice in the rising generation ben that
i want to be a part of that and be a
part of that conversation
have youth in america understand the
ideals of freedom
basis of the american founding and how
they're relevant to all of the all of
the hot debates that are taking place uh
every single day in the midst of this
administration
so let's talk about some of those
debates obviously vice president pence
we were promised unity this is the big
thing unity when president biden took
office and i asked at the time after his
inaugural address he when he when he
said unity that could mean one of two
things either we're gonna cool things
down we're gonna look for some sort of
bipartisan compromise everything is
gonna calm down now or it meant we're
going to cram through our agenda and if
you disagree with us you're threatening
unity and it's pretty obvious which one
of those two things has obviously
materialized at this point this is most
obvious in terms of his recent covid
decisions in which he is now using the
bureaucratic state as a tool of the
executive branch to basically just
ignore the entire legislative branch and
use mandates that are beyond the power
of any
executive branch agency that i've ever
seen it's pretty astonishing
well the latest announcement of mandates
using osha rules is clearly
unconstitutional but you know look take
a step back i'll i will always be proud
of what the american people accomplish
during our tenure leading the white
house coronavirus task force i mean you
look you look back at those days a year
and a half ago
we reinvented testing from a standing
start within six months we had
we had done more than a billion tests
all around the country we uh we saw to
the delivery and manufacture literally
of billions of medical supplies no
american was ever denied
a level of health care critical care
that they needed
no one was ever denied a ventilator
i tell people only in america would you
see the kind of mobilization
that we saw
in in 2020 then the development of
therapeutics the aid to small businesses
and to your point ben everything that we
did
with the congress of the united states
to aid families to aid small businesses
to stand up our national response was
done on a broad
bipartisan basis and then it was
i have to tell you it was shocking to me
that that right out of the gate the
first coveted bill that passed passed on
a partisan basis under the biden
administration but it set the tone for
everything they've done driving open
borders efforts to defund the police
trampling our liberties
and uh and and this latest literally
power grab
with a national mandate i mean i i
couldn't be more proud that in nine
months we developed two safe and
effective vaccines we encourage everyone
to get a vaccine
karen and i got vaccinated back in
december
on national television but at the end of
the day even even though president biden
said it's not about freedom
america is about freedom and and i will
tell you last thought i
i just never heard an american president
speak to the american people the way
president biden did last week i mean i i
don't know about you no it has punished
me to
have the president of the united states
say
to the american people
i have been patient but my patience is
running thin
i mean he works for us
yeah it's amazing he's not he's not my
father
if you're my dad you get to talk to me
like that if you're not my dad you
really don't get to talk to me like that
and particularly
and and particularly when the president
of the united states has not been
transparent about his covet policy
particularly when his administration has
been completely politically driven in so
much of its coveted policy ranging from
school reopening policies to whether you
should mask or unmask or not mask or
children should mask you know all of
this has been really botched politically
in a radical way i mean even in that
speech just to take an example we have
him saying that his patience is running
thin with the unvaccinated but he
literally says in the speech both that
the vaccinated are safe from the
unvaccinated and also that the
vaccinated are deeply unsafe from the
unvaccinated and we must protect the
vaccinated from the unvaccinated well if
i'm unvaccinated and i listen to the
president of the united states tell me
that even after i'm vaccinated i'm still
vulnerable to the the unvaccinated that
might make me think twice about getting
the vaccine he's actively talking down
the efficacy of the vaccine in order to
push forward mandates that are that
would be unnecessary if again we
recognized a couple of basic truths one
that people are responsible for their
own decision making when it comes to
this and two that every adult in the
united states has the capacity to go
back get a vaccine today right
that's right which is really you know i
i use the from i'm actually working on a
book and i just keep reflecting on our i
mean we launched the greatest national
mobilization since world war ii ben and
you know that you've covered it like
like very few others
i mean only in america could we have
done what we did i mean i remember when
president trump said that we were going
to have a vaccine by the end of the year
that
all the media political everyone scoffed
at it
and let's remember that joe biden and
kamala harris
both spent the entire year 2020
undermining public confidence in the
vaccine
i was in a national debate with kamala
harris in which she again repeated that
she wouldn't take a vaccine if it came
from president donald trump and i called
her out i said i said you've got to stop
playing politics with people's lives so
they spent all last year undermining and
then when this year arrives
i think the first time president biden
ever acknowledged that our
administration was responsible through
operation warp speed of the vaccine was
about seven months in and it was just a
passing reference i mean the the fact
that they they steadfastly refused
uh to give credit where credit is due to
the extraordinary innovation of american
research companies catalyzed by the
leadership the president set into motion
in operation warp speed was it was a
deeply partisan
stance and i and i also think that it it
undermined public confidence in the
vaccine as well so look uh it is about
freedom you know my new podcast is
entitled american freedom with mike
pence i just when you you heard the
president of the united states not only
scolding
scolding americans for not taking the
vaccine
but the scolding governors uh for
uh for managing their states according
to their own lives
it
i it just and then he said it's not
about freedom america is about freedom
it's what explains
this extraordinary
unprecedented prosperity uh of of of uh
the american people over
over what will be in
in a not long period of time 250 years
of history and i i i want to be a part
of that conversation for the rest of my
life we'll get some more with former
vice president mike pence in just one
moment first have you ever wondered why
internet access is a lot cheaper these
days like 30 or 40 bucks a month well
that's because isps aren't just making
money off your subscription fees they're
also making money off of your data your
internet activity they sell your history
and your data to big tech companies so
what is the best way to make sure that
100 of your data is encrypted and that
your internet provider can't get a hold
of it you guessed it expressvpn
expressvpn creates a secure tunnel
between all your devices and the
internet so everything you do online is
encrypted it reroutes your connection
through a secure server which blocks
your internet provider from seeing
everything you do online all they can
see is that you are connected to an
expressvpn server but they can't see
anything other than that it's not just
for phone or computer expressvpn works
on all your devices it works on your
tablets your smart tv even your router
so your entire family can always stay
protected and i can't stress this enough
it's really easy to use like you click
one button it is now downloaded you
click a button again and now it is
working on your computer or your phone
or wherever you want it to work and
you're protected your data is your
business protected at
expressvpn.com visit
expressvpn.com to get three extra months
i've expressed vpn protection for free
that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com ben to learn more
vice president pence uh just a pretty
specific question here did the
administration ever reach out to you or
president trump and ask about doing some
sort of bipartisan ad campaign about
pushing the vaccine because it seems to
me if you actually want to get people
vaccinated then you actually should talk
to the people on the right and this
administration has steadfastly refused
to do so which really suggests they're
not as much interested in getting people
vaccinated as they are in playing
politics with the with the vaccinations
when you want to convince people you
don't treat them like children you
actually try and make an appeal to them
you actually try and convince them that
it's in their best interest it seems to
me that an obvious move here would have
been to try and cut some sort of
bipartisan ad campaign with you and
kamala harris and with president trump
and president and president biden saying
you know we disagree on a lot of things
but we all agree that the vaccines are a
godsend and you should go get one
well yeah it never happened and i and
look it's
but i i go back to they spent the whole
of 2020 undermining public confidence in
the vaccine i mean they
made kamal harris and joe biden again
and again said any vaccine coming under
president donald trump
uh that they you know they they would
hesitate to take it that they undermined
that we could
but we do we developed two safe and
effective vaccines and now we're sitting
here today and 75 of the american people
have received one vaccine shot already i
mean it's when we sat down the week
after i became chairman of the white
house coronavirus task force we brought
in
all of the major research companies in
the cabinet room president sitting there
i'm sitting there we said to them
all right how soon can we get medicines
they said well therapeutics we can get
we can move pretty quickly on maybe by
the summer or the fall we said what
about vaccines they said
vaccines take four to seven years
if you can develop them
and right then and there the president
our entire team said how do we
accelerate that without compromising
safety at all that's where operation
warp speed was born it was an innovative
approach that essentially said look once
you have an efficacy signal that's a
fancy schmancy term for once you once
you've got a vaccine that looks like
it's going to work
early in the clinical trials we'll just
pay you to make it while you keep
testing it
and then if at the end it doesn't work
we'll we'll just pay for it anyway and
that was operation warp speed and so we
we were literally the day we left office
we were vaccinating a million americans
a day
okay
and yet this administration came in if
you may not remember this but i think i
almost fell off my chair
when uh i think it was about a week into
the new administration president biden
said something to the effect of
we didn't have a vaccine when i took off
right
which was it was
a strange statement given the fact that
there was a picture of him taking the
vaccine a week and a half before he had
been vaccinated
he had been vaccinated but he literally
said that but i you know that's another
topic right but
the the reality is that you're a hundred
percent right that uh and i tried to set
this tone from the very first
coronavirus task force briefing that we
were all in this together
uh this administration could have come
in
and set a tone on on encouraging and
everyone's individual decision without
mandates encouraging people to take
advantage of this
medical miracle
a vaccine available through operation
warp speed
but doing it at a bipartisan basis but
also also moving legislation coveted
legislation on a bipartisan basis
they didn't do that that was a partisan
vote
for the first time out of the gate in
this administration and everything they
have done every day since
uh has been has been designed like you
said at the very beginning but
it's about dividing it's it's about it
literally is exactly the opposite of the
of the false unity messages they
projected from
joe biden's basement in 2020.
so but vice president pence um you know
the the other obvious part of the news
cycle that we've seen i really think
that joe biden's vaccine mandates are in
part an attempt to distract from the
failures in afghanistan the reason i say
that is because i think that he is i
think he understands that there's a very
solid shot that these mandates get
struck down in court uh in fact i think
that there's a solid possibility that
this may actually redown to the benefit
of those of us who hate the
administrative state because i think
that there's every possibility that this
gets elevated to the supreme court level
the supreme court looks at how osha is
interpreting its own rules and they just
say you know we're not doing chevron
deference anymore right we're no longer
going to allow administrative agencies
to essentially adjudicate the meaning of
statute now we get to adjudicate that
would actually be a positive result but
i think joe biden doesn't care as much
about what happens with any of that as
he does about simply moving past the
afghanistan news cycle which continues
to unfold there is something incredibly
galling about watching the 20th
anniversary of 9 11 memorials and seeing
the president of the united states talk
about unity and strength and courage at
the same time that the taliban that day
were flying their flag over the
presidential palace in kabul solely
thanks to this administration's
decision as not only to pull out but how
to pull out
well i i said early on the biden
administration's disastrous withdrawal
from
afghanistan uh was a foreign policy
humiliation unlike anything this country
has endured since the iran hostage
crisis
and it didn't have to happen
um it it grieves my heart um
when when i
when i reflect on the loss of 13 u.s
service members but when you you think
of the chaos the catastrophe
uh that took place at kabul airport and
the fact that literally
they ordered our military out of kabul
air force base
in the middle of the night without
alerting our allies
and left americans behind
and left america's allies behind it's
just it was unconscionable and um
uh and i i will say to all of your
listeners around the country it would
not have happened
uh if the trump pence administration had
been
in office i mean the deal that we struck
with the taliban in february of 2020 had
three criteria number one
you don't harm any americans
and literally for the next 18 months it
was not a single american casualty in
afghanistan
number two you work with the afghan
national government you work out a
coalition government number three you
you agree not to become a safe haven for
the kind of terrorist organizations
uh al qaeda or isis k th that struck our
country 20 years ago right in al-qaeda
uh
the president i remember i was in the
oval office when he spoke to mueller
uh he had him on the speaker phone
and the president said to him and this
remember how ben you
this was a couple of weeks after we took
down the iranian general qasim solomonia
who was responsible for the death of
hundreds of american service members
uh in iraq
uh and this was just four months after
we took down abu bakr al-baghdadi and we
took down the isis caliphate
and so the president says to the head of
the taliban he said look we all want to
end the violence
but if you break this deal we're going
to hit you harder than we've ever hit
you before
and you could just hear in the tone
of the taliban leader that he understood
that
and literally the fact that there was
not an american casualty for 18 months
proves my point
that they knew we meant business
the idea was that we would have an
orderly withdrawal that took place
before the fighting season began in may
and and and yet this administration
comes in having overturned everything
that we've done i mean think about it
the they overturned all of the policies
that were working to secure our border
i mean they've been advancing uh
economic policies that are now driving
record inflation they've been trampling
on liberties
but on this one they kept saying we
can't do anything differently except
they did
they extended for no particular reason
at the time for the withdrawal initially
announced they were going to set the
date of september 11th until that was
recognized as as inexplicable
and then moved it back so in the middle
of the fighting season they made the
decision
uh to move american troops out and i i
just have to tell you it
it was a disgrace
but i want to say to people all over the
country listening in especially those
families of service men and women
who served in afghanistan over the last
20 years
nothing this administration
did no failings of the biden
administration
in the last month will ever diminish
the extraordinary contributions
to our freedom and our security that
everyone who served in afghanistan
advanced uh since 9 11 forward i mean
september 11th happens and we we've
literally had six million americans that
have stepped forward and put on
the uniform of the united states
some seven thousand have fallen uh in
service and
uh and twenty four hundred in
afghanistan and and i wanna tell you the
fact that we came to this weekend this
past weekend
20 years on we hadn't had another major
terrorist event
on american soil is is a tribute to all
of those who stepped forward and served
they said here am i send me
and i truly do believe that
all those who wore the uniform and
served in afghanistan despite this
administration's disgraceful
disastrous withdrawal all those who
serve will be
will be remembered in the annals of
american history for their contributions
to our freedom
as vice president mike pence you can
check out his brand new podcast american
freedom with mike pence in partnership
with our friends over at young america's
foundation vice president pence thanks
so much for the time and good luck with
the new venue that's that's pretty
awesome
thank you ben great to be with you
remember that was the administration
right there those were the bad guys
right according to the media according
to your friends on facebook these were
the people who definitely needed to be
thrown out of office because they were
norm breaking and terrible and what we
got in their place was a doddering old
fool who spends his days figuring out
how to violate the constitution in
pursuit of extraordinarily invasive
policy and surrender abroad
it turns out that the bad tweets they
were bad and also the president makes an
awful lot of policy and who you elect
presidents of the united states has a
rather large impact on the daily life
that you lead and your friends lead and
your families lead as well people ought
to remember that going forward because
it turns out that the folks the media
say are really bad people very often are
not and the folks that the media say are
really good people very often are the
people most likely to violate your most
closely held and most dearly held
freedoms
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed